the adult film star who claims she had
sex with President Trump in 2006 is now
suing his personal lawyer stormy Daniels
described the alleged relationship on
Sunday's 60 minutes and said she was
threatened in order to keep it quiet in
2011 Daniels added attorney Michael
Cohen to an existing lawsuit yesterday
after his lawyer demanded an apology
major Garrett is at the White House
where the president is not talking major
good morning good morning president
Trump left it to a spokesman and the
lawyer of his lawyer to explain a
$130,000 payment about a week and a half
before the 2016 election to stormy
Daniels the explanation it was business
nothing personal the president strongly
clearly and has consistently denied
these underlying claims deputy press
secretary Raj Shah dismissed adult film
star stormy Daniels statements to 60
minutes about the alleged 2006 affair
you had such a yeah Shah was asked why
if the affair never happened did Cohen
pay Daniels I would have Michael Cohen
address any specifics regarding this
disagreement that you're referring to
but look false charges are settled out
of court all the time and this is
nothing outside the ordinary Cohen's
lawyer David Schwartz said Daniels was
paid to protect the Trump family
business not to defuse a possibly
explosive campaign issue he kept her
silence to protect business Daniel sued
Cohen on Monday for defamation accusing
him of insinuating she was lying I'm not
okay with being made out to be a liar
besides a vague fake news tweet Monday
morning President Trump has said nothing
about Daniels or former Playboy Playmate
Karen McDougal who last week disclosed
an alleged 10-month affair in 2006 and
2007 with mr. Trump both women said sex
was consensual
unlike 16 women who have levelled
accusations against the president every
woman lied when they came forward to
hurt my campaign total fabrication
neither Daniels nor McDougald accused
mr. Trump of harassment or abuse
the president like millions of other
Americans watched the 60 Minutes
interview and according to The
Washington Post has since told
associates Daniels wasn't his type those
who remember conversations with mr.
Trump during the campaign remember him
denying the affair but in no way
indicating Daniels couldn't have been
his type Nora all right major thank you
very much